اه نشير للمشاهدين انه هذه التطورات همم
الان كما نشاهد ااه ادرام النيران في
حاويات للقمامه وايضا همم في همم محاوله
لاغلاق الطرقات من قبل المتظاهرين بعد همم
مواجهات
ومناوشات وعمليات كارو وفرح بينها وبين
القوات الامنيه هناك تعزيزات القوات
الامنيه خروج ايضا وتجمع للاكراد كان وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه السمح بذلك قال سنسمح
للاكراد بالقروش في تظاهرات سلميه ولكن
هذا تجمع تحول الى مواجهات مباشر يتم من
خلالها رفق القوات الامنيه بما يتوفر
بالنسبه للمتظاهرين هناك غضب لما حدث
اليوم وفي ايجاز سريع رجل مشتبه تم القاء
القبض عليه همم كان يحمل همم سلاح
وقد اطلق النار بالقرب من مقر ثقافي
للاكراد وسقط ثلاثه قتله وقد تم الاعلان
عن انهم الثلاثه من الاكراد اما بالنسبه
للبقيه فاتنين بحاله حرجه بحسب المعلومات
التي وردتنا اذا تجمع للاكراد غاضب عمليات
تكسير كما نشاهد للسيارات ايضا للمطاعم
المحيطه للذكر هذه المنطقه التي نتحدث
عنها فيها مطاعم كرديه واخرى تركيه طبعا
هناك نوع من ابعاد الشبهات عن اي خلفيه
همم تركيه ان تكون وراء هذه العمليه وزير
الداخليه
الفرنسي قال بان الرجل تحرك بمفرده ولكن
هذا لم يمنع من خروج الاكراد في هذا
التجمع بحاله من الغضب وتحولت باريس همم
قبل يوم من عيد الميلاد
الى ساحه مواجهه ما بينها وما بين القوى
الامنيه ما بين الاكراد والقوات الامنيه
قبل قليل ايضا شاهدنا ان هناك فيما يبدو
اصابه لرجل من رجال الامن خلال المظاهرات
شاهدنا عددنا متظاهرين يقومون طبعا بنشق
القوات الامنيه بما توفر امامهم من حجاره
وغيرها بالمقابل رجال الامن تعاملت همم
فيما تراه مناسبا بقسوه مع المتظاهرين
واطلقت الغاز المسيء للدموع في محاوله
لتفريقهم